well I could play mark shy play mark I
think he also started streaming let's
play mark wait my ratings higher than
his how is that possible
I forgot that was a thing
what does he play against before he
plays Smith Maura I don't want to play
Smith Maura well let's play knight c6
play something a bit different let's get
rid of this dumb sound even though it's
a peaceful sound all my time I'll play
d6
yeah we'll play some some Puetz 906 I
have to take this seriously this is
rated I'm about a hundred points high
rated and do this hello to people in the
chat and I'll play castling I've have
not really studied this too extensively
I assume the ship g4 is standard and
years of e5 maybe taking and then five
looks nice gain some time initially if
d5 maybe Knight d4 if takes consider
taking with pawn Wow
so can I get away with no I can't
I'm he's offering a draw why is he
offering a draw but it's rated that
would ruin my rating do I have Knight g4
here
my g4 is actually really interesting I
don't want to draw a g4g for ticks
ding Knight g4 is working we could just
be simplifying
it's interesting I'm unleashing my
Bishop battery pawn the bishop pawn
battery attacking d4
I'm also hitting this bishop so if he
takes her pushes I just take the bishop
first if he takes either away I take
this way and we're just trading it's
kind of a fancy way of trading but I'm
opening up the diagonal I think it's
slightly favours me you're eating pizza
that's nice
I'm drinking tea hello - hoof Nagle's
liquid sword is back yeah I have to take
the knight to keep it positional could
take the bishop
it was very positional actually take the
bishop Queen f6 or 95 first
it's a very unusual time control it's 15
seconds
with a 45 second or with a fifth it's
only 15 second increment it's relatively
rapid hmm complain 95 whoa it's bits
it's from Culver and thanks for being
such a positive influence
thanks Hoover I appreciate the comment I
think I want to play rook over key
episode u7 it still looks fine you wanna
maybe I'll play this I'll play this
first to manage my time the paw process
of chess isn't there a leg of Bob Ross
twitch emotes
I think oh man I swallowed the tea the
wrong way I'm drinking spicy sweet tea
I play rookie seven rookie seven looks
natural
maybe wrote d8 first Africa me when I
play b6
considering 95 looks weird but I'm gonna
do it
c4 is a square I can potentially control
so night c4 might c4 is interesting
Queen d4 probably take stakes c5 also
interesting see that looks weakening now
also this is a fork kind of not sure if
I'd be threatening to take hey nice job
let's start with this was this named
beanie Boresha very nice that's good to
hear
wait I can take the pond did he not see
that or he's threatening some trap Queen
d5 but then b6 I think I can take the
pawn 27 seconds ah so he's threatening
this but that's fine I just moved back
some initiative of the rook here
trying to only I'm trying to preserve
time for critical moments so I'm up upon
my Queen should go back to like f6 where
it belongs
I did not start the stream with the
intention of playing a sermon I thought
I was just gonna do viewer challenges
okay now he's doing interesting things I
could take takes once he six takes we
trade a bit he Wednesday seven in the
end no he can't win a seven because G
three so let's take it's gonna take on B
seven that's a move Wow takes trying to
figure this out if I take here it
doesn't quite work or does it probably
not okay let's take there
am I gonna be down upon at the end of
this line takes it's not so bad it's
actually kind of a weird queen pawn
ending cuz now I play a five probably oh
no it's equal material oh it's a weird
ending I can play this to take stakes
mmm
it was very interesting ending let's
play a five my structure is arguably a
bit better this King is less safe I have
more shelter for my king I have less
time though
so the pawns fixed here so I want to
play this and then just win the pawn
Queens tied down to g3 expecting Queen
f3 we're not for also possible it could
play Queen d7 not much time though play
Queen d7 13 Queen d1 also tying the
Queen down to this pawn if I trade
Queens I think it's just a winning end
game like if Queens just come off the
board guess it depends specifically if
we do end up trading because I can
create a pastor on the Kings side with
my majority this majority means nothing
that's a good move I think I wants to
play with this move so maybe now it's
time to it's time to move quicker Queen
up three probably Queen g5 mmm
let's play Queen f3 expecting this and
probably taking and what else does white
do
King each to I guess maybe Mikey Queen
can plant itself here could be my square
King H to Queenie - it's probably just
perpetual
King H 2 H 5 could be interesting you
need to H 5 Queen d8 tix
check I'll throw in the check
this could just be a draw each five it's
getting a little bit of time not sure if
I want it if I take I could take their
oh no black has pure white has perpetual
Queen f1o h5 is probably the way to go
let's try it
I don't think there's any risk with this
if I want to I can play I can give
perpetual after light takes one c7
Goldust Tory in the chat I would say hi
to more people but I'm kind of
pressuring on time it's a weird time
control so White has no more checks
either this
yeah this I probably have to give
perpetual I was dreaming of like Queen
each one meet
to do queen of wander there's some g5
idea actually
whoa g v g5 work wait
daya I had g5 in this position oh man I
should have considered that not sure if
it worked though to analyze later maybe
I'll get it again depending what light
does Oh King each 3g5 first of all it's
a threat they're threatening this this
this I don't think I'm threatening
anything
also this idea that queen takes f7 kills
all the fun
thanks for the bits hey Eric what advice
what you did on how to calculate best
moves I am about 1,400 rated that's what
I'm trying to do right now let's
calculate the best moves g v g5 queen c4
oh there's a nice no I'm not seeing it I
could played this move though I wouldn't
see two let's try it
I'll win c2 and now the goal is to win a
four with check not sure if it's
possible to try this mmm
that's tricky though Queen do you want I
don't want the King to escape too far
[Music]
so the game continues
we have three here King III I run out of
checks
let's try Queen D 3 I'd like to play for
a win but it's not easy but I could play
no I can't play g5 like King g7 maybe
and c4 expected
okay if I want to play on I could play
King g7 Python I lose a five so I could
play Queen d5 for than c4 I take a four
yeah I didn't see it not sure if I have
a win there g5 I should have considered
g5 I don't think it worked
so I'm just curious if I either win like
around here so yeah I really should have
considered this no yeah computers not
finding anything concrete's same Queen
f3 we have three threatens mates that's
okay so if I want to play for a win I
should play g5 and Queen c4
yeah there's some interesting pressure
here between c6 ah f6 this really
working takes I guess this is working
because I win all the ponds and I have
h4 when necessary
not crazy it's a hard time control until
I calculate so precisely
you